انتم جلسات للبرلمان اللبناني حتى الساعه
لم تفلح فيها الكتل النيابيه في التوافق
على اسم رئيس جمهوريه جديد في ظل شعور
رئاسي وحكومه تصريف اعمال محدوده الصلاحيه
على قوه التغيير وعلى المعارضه التقليديه
التواصل والتواصل الى اسم جدي في ما يتعلق
بانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه معوض بحسب حزب
الله هو مرشح مواجهه في ليث هناك امنيه
لانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه ولا اعتقد بان
الاطراف السياسيه اللبنانيه الاساسيه
والاحزاب التقليديه جاده في موضوع انتخاب
الرئيس وهذا الشعور سيستمر الى السنه
القادمه
السياسيه لانتخاب رئيس جديد وتطبيق
الاصلاحات المطلوبه قبل استفها للازمه
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه وفواه الاوان
على ثلاثه مليار دولار وايضا من بعد منا
حصول الابناء على 11 مليار دولار من مؤتمر
الصادر في حال اتم الاستحاض مطلوب في وقت
يسيطر فيه الخلاف بين الكتل النيابيه على
مواصفات الرئيس يتخوف الشارع اللبناني
منفلتان امني ومعيشيه باثر على حياتنا
باثر على لان الوضع
السياسي بالبلد كل وليدات الوضع الامني
والوضع الاقتصادي همم اذا انت ما كنت حاسه
حالك عايشه بامان بدوله فيها استقرار
مدرسه سياسي او امنه او اقتصاده ما هتحسي
حالك مرتاحه للمره الرابعه يقع لبنان في
فخ الشعور الرئاسي منذنين لها الاستقلال
فهل ستنجح جلسات المتتاليه للبرلمان
بانتخاب رئيس جمهوريه جديد في وقت قريب
وتفعيل مؤسسات الدوله